[Music]
[Music]
listen to music
ad-free with song my premium for only
$7.99 you'll have unlimited access to
our spotlight artists of the month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no sir I can take care of that oh I got
it thank you oh no problem is it
anything I can take care of for you no
I'm good thank you do you have anybody
looking for safety calls because they're
really hard to find and hardly anybody
ever finds him I'm all good on cars
yeah I can help you with anything else
I'm good thanks sure all right we have
cotton rope nautical rope tow rope
polypropylene rope parachute rope try
rope rope crimes
pretty much anything here beneath no
idea that it's many times over oh man
what you need a corset ah just a good
house whoa no house rope so you doing
some remodeling yeah yeah just I mean I
have like a hammer a new drill and I
feel like I need a good rope in the kid
okay well we have this nice
general-purpose rope probably need
something a little more substantial okay
oh we can do that see some cases an
earthquake or something I need to kick
open the door and whip out a safety so a
rope taking hold your own bodyweight
perfect laughter what do you weigh about
175 155 well we have this nice climbing
rope
you have anything less colorful you know
something that we use to type you pour
down in a train tracks back in the old
days okay
natural fiber rope perfect I know what
you're doing okay
my respecting taking a life in your own
hands wanting to get out while you at
the top everything's [ __ ] anyways who
says quantity of quality right have you
ever seen a dead body no
I was in the army back in the day thank
you for your service I wasn't exactly on
the frontlines I was a cook anyways it
was his PFC he was on kitchen duty found
out he couldn't take it anymore
got drunk wild for our watch found out
that we didn't lock the gas ovens and
boom because whom the hell when I [ __ ]
with the number right yeah you know
people [ __ ] themselves when they die no
wait really it's a mess man hey you got
tarps in our 39f thank you
[Music]
[Music]
damnit
[Music]
[Music]